good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 38 87 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 38 87 a is to be housed
within a standard humanoid containment
cell at site 17 a one-way mirror is to
be positioned on the opposite side of
the bed at least two personnel should be
stationed in the observation room at all
times SCP 38 87 a must receive a vitamin
integrator with its ordinary food intake
due to minor health issues to maintain a
CB 38 87 A's mental health and ensure
its cooperation it has been allowed
control of the lights in sight itself in
case of an emergency control of set
lights can still be overridden by
monitoring personnel in the observation
room to limit or otherwise in paragraph
behavior from SCP 38 87 be SCP 38 87 a
must be supplied with new socks every
three days since containment SCP 38 87 a
has made the following requests one
computer with an internet connection
denied one computer with access to SCP
38 87 a's old game gallery approved
under the condition any updates are made
off-site a housecat denied a gaming
controller approved
access to up-to-date entertainment media
approved access to on-site recreational
areas denied as CP 38 87 is allowed
access to the on-site gym for health
issues once per week while accompanied
by at least one level 3 personnel
provided with a 320 Lux flashlight
description SCP 38 87 a is a 24 year old
woman of European descent formerly known
as SCP 38 87 a was a resident of
Missouri SCP 38 87 a has been in
complete cooperation with the foundation
after the events of incident 38 87 a1
SCP 38 87 B is a humanoid entity 2.35
metres tall with skin that is greyish
green in color it has two long horns
growing from its forehead similar in
form to Oryx dama a scimitar horned Oryx
and long black hair grown from its head
neck and shoulder blades SCP 38 87 bees
eyes have yellow sclera with no visible
pupil a SCP 38 87 bee's mouth hosts
three rows of fangs similar in shape and
arrangement to the Carcharias taurus
more commonly known as a bull shark SCP
38 87 B has elongated arms forcing it to
remain in a hunched posture and to move
on all fours most of the time it
possesses a long hairless tail similar
to a Rattus norvegicus common rat se p38
87b possesses both male and female
reproductive organs testing is shown
that any substance or material presented
to se be 38 87 so far is able to be used
as sustenance but it has shown a clear
predilection for SCP 38 87 a's socks SCP
38 87 B was initially believed to be
capable of manifesting through any dark
area within a 5 meter radius around the
CP 3880
seven a favoring the bed after further
testing it has been noted that SCP 38
87b can always manifest under whatever
item SCP 38 87 a identifies as its bed
regardless of its distance from SCP 38
87 a SCP 38 87 B is extremely sensitive
to light its skin rapidly develops
blisters and open wounds when exposed to
levels of light above 20 Lux forcing SCP
38 87 be to flee and disappear into the
closest dark area the process through
which it escapes is currently not
understood and is undergoing further
study DNA analysis of SCP 38 87 B's
tissue samples have revealed that it
shares genetic material with Homo
sapiens Oryx dama Carcharias Torres
Rattus norvegicus Rinella marina a cane
toad and an unidentified additional
genetic component SCP 38 87 B's presence
has been observed to disrupt and damage
digital recording devices with said
interference worsening the more of SCP
38 87 B is exposed as CP 38 87 B has
shown aversion towards foundation
personnel but has avoided any hostile
actions to date so as to not upset as CP
38 87 a SCP 38 87 a has shown a strong
emotional attachment to SCP 38 87 B and
has often been observed acting in an
affectionate manner with SCP 38 87 B
when they're alone incident 33 87 a 1 SC
P 38 87 a and SCP 38 87 B were recovered
the 2014 after the reported death of
Robert SCP 38 87 A's partner at the time
during a party eyewitnesses stated that
SCP 38 87 a's date was humiliating SCP
3880 7 8
front of the guests and acting in a
demeaning manner as was reported to be
characteristic of their relationship SCP
38 87 be manifested itself under a table
assaulting until SCP 38 87 days date had
her limbs completely severed
after which SCP 38 87 Biddy manifested
when the authorities arrived SCP 38 87 a
was in a state of shock the
interrogation log 38 87 a1 for further
details interview 38 87 a one
interviewer undercover agent Bellamy
interviewee SCP 38 87 a notes this
interview was taken two hours after
incident 33 87 a 1 playing log now how
are you feeling didn't mean for it to
happen it's not all that I please miss
Thank You time no no I'm ok officer I
have to make it right somehow this is
all my fault
I see very well maybe you can help us
shed some light on what happened the
other eyewitnesses said I'm treating you
very well before the incident happened
am I correct
hey well yes she she was being a bit
rough and then the entity attack is
there anything you can tell me about
that creature any idea why it attacked I
believe she was trying to protect me oh
gosh
I it's crazy I always imagined that was
crazy but College you're gonna think I'm
gonna kiss - I need to hear what you
have to say before I make any decisions
please miss need to make sure it doesn't
hurt anyone else is there anything at
all you can tell us
oh no she she would she's not evil
I promised she wouldn't hurt a fly
please she Brenda used to be my
boogeyman
could you please elaborate but well you
know when your your kids and you think
the craziest things hide in the darkness
when I lived in my parents home was
sorry
very old an old farmhouse in the country
with this old barn filled with rats we
we even had a well anyway there were
always a lot of creaking noises so
whenever I went to bed she was stalking
me in the dark you know I always saw her
tail sticking out art her pale arms
reaching up to grab me so I pants into
the blankets and well I was afraid but I
was very little sounds silly now doesn't
it well the tool please continue so well
she kept creeping under my bed in the
shadows moving things knocking things
over she was a mean one
my parents thought she was something in
a minute to play monster broke even
though it really was her fault it all
went on like this for years I was a very
lonely child
I understand so when did you first
realize it wasn't
something you may have won well first I
started to see here less and less like
old uh what else would you expect right
but when I was from faulty I think maybe
fifteen she came back it was late at
night my parents were arguing as usual
and I hits my room I was close to the
bed and she touched me I was scared
shitless but we've harped she's been
with me since she's a good person I
promise please this is all my fault
thank you for your time this some people
will want to speak to you further
I'll keep you here until that after the
interview at CP 38 87 a was escorted to
a secure cell before meeting foundation
personnel who explained the situation as
long as the CP 3880 7b would not be hurt
at CP 38 87 a promised full cooperation
interview 38 87 b1 interviewer dr.
Tanner interviewee SCP 38 87 be notes
this was the first interview made with
SCP 38 87 be interview occurred while
SCP 38 87 a was asleep after their
arrival at their first stop in site SCP
38 87 be addressed dr. Tanner during a
routine check of the room it was the
first observation of a CP 38 87 be
playing log no sorry
I didn't mean to disturb you are you the
NTV scp-387 they spoke of I assume so
mmm yeah I would assume the same don't
wake her or a deer he needs her say she
hasn't done anything wrong
it was all my fault then I assure you
this is not a punishment we're doing
this so she could be safe and protected
and the same thing goes for you too we
can keep you safe I am safe as long as
she is she was my child and I've already
broken enough rules now and to add to
that now I've got her in trouble with
her own people
can you elaborate what do you mean when
you say scp-387 a was your child isn't
she daughter come oh yeah duh I mean
kids are my kinds first source of food
as some like me just released on fear
and stress and anxiety while others tend
to be a bit more rough what did you have
a monster under your bed too when you
were a kid smarty pants not that I can
remember though okay how weird anyway I
was supposed to feed on there until she
was like 10 and then move on to another
kid that's what we do since children are
such easy prey but I kind of stopped
with her opener
she's so innocent
it's sweet she was also nice day even
when she was scared she started tossing
me socks to use first night she started
to grow up she stopped calling to me
until their parents started the divorce
she needed someone to listen all right
so I take you a very good relationship
with her could you elaborate on what
rules you broke the laws made by your
kind what can you tell me about your
species I broke your own and they exiled
me to my camp I can't go back up there I
can show you interview 38 87 823
interviewer doctor garden interviewee
SCP 38 87 a playing log No good morning
SAV 38 you said in a did you sleep well
yes we did Mia gonna talk to up but I
think it obviously that's good there now
today I would like you to tell me a
little more about the theory you told me
about last time about how SCP 38 a SMB
came to be do you think we can tackle
that
ah yeah sure I can do that okay so last
time you said you creates an SCP 38 87
be based on what scared you can you
elaborate on that
yeah of course it is quite simple
actually I mean you have seen Brenda oh
yeah I'm trying to keep now but when I
was a kid she was very frightening the
teeth like it
I remember my parents brought me to an
aquarium months and in the tanks there
was this massive bull shark it had the
craziest look and those fangs were so
scary and that night go figure
Brenda smiles and I saw the same fangs
mm-hmm I understand the same reasoning
goes for the rest of its body her body
but yes I guess so I can tell you for
sure I was scared of the rats crawling
through the fields our house and I I
mean when I was little like very well I
was apparently scared oops
at least that's what mom used to tell me
hence like Brenda such a blood chest it
does make sense right it would look like
it so you think you are the cause for
scp-387 beasts existence but it depends
on you to exist is the only thing that
makes sense
are you I I met up so that's why she
helps me she keeps me company she
doesn't make me feel alone and she
listens to me with her not really alone
I mean when I don't need a she run
Isha's and she pops out again when I do
I understand thank you for your time at
CP 38 87 a we can stop here for today
interview 38 87 b7 interviewer doctor
garden interviewee SCP 38 87 be notes
this interview was taken while SCP 38 87
a was taking part in its weekly training
session playing log now gonna be SCP
3287 be is everything okay hungry I'm
quite sure we had SCP 38-7 any feed here
sucks yesterday with anilina socks are
just a snack well I understand her
well-being in high consideration
shouldn't that be nice to them of course
I am
I'm starving miracles around here is not
enough for me
I'm sure we can find a solution to this
problem I'll make sure to make my
superiors aware now about that interview
no no
additional notes at this point the
camera feed becomes completely unstable
as dr. Walker who is stationed in the
observation room at the time reported
that he watched as a CP 38 87 B's arms
emerge from under the bed and seized dr.
garden before dragging her into the
darkness disappearing from the sight as
CP 38 87 a was immediately recalled to
its room and prompted to call for SCP
3880 7b but without any apparent result
13 minutes after disappearing dr. garden
was suddenly expelled from under the bed
bruised completely wet misuk her shoes
glasses and socks but mostly unharmed
dr. garden was later interviewed
interview 38 87 alpha interviewer dr.
Walker
interviewee dr. garden notes this
interview was taken after a preliminary
medical check following the events of
interview log 38 87 b7 playing log no
how are you feeling
are you sure you want to do this now
it can wait out for a proper medical
examine medical check if you prefer I'm
fine thank you do not treat me like a
child
let's get this over with as you wish
yeah can you tell me what happened after
a cp3 87b grabbed you yes after the end
of the grabs me I immediately tried to
free myself even though I knew it would
be almost impossible to lose he drags me
under the bed and into the darkness with
it but once I was beneath the bed frame
it downwards as if three to four you
know the sensation when you suddenly
feel yourself falling nestled in pool at
your belly I felt that the light of the
room vanished and it was all black page
black it lasted
say 15 seconds yes 15 seconds before I
reached the crowd was this EP 3087 be
with you during all of this
it was holding on to me while I was
falling but once I reached the floor it
was nowhere I felt it was there I didn't
see it but on the other hand I couldn't
see what was around me I was in a cave
I'd say roughly 50 meters in diameter
Black Hawk I think some kind of crime
there was a waterfall a lake and Lila
jams later into walls I would say I
missed if not for the fact they were
glowing like lots and lots of little
candles oh and there was a hole where
some light was coming in to the ceiling
suddenly well that is surprising nothing
else particularly peculiar there opened
the contrary right after I looked her up
I noticed that there were a loss of
other hosts in the cavern ceiling but
they were all dark we're looking at the
sunny one I own a sword appeared to be a
river angling from it indicate itself
there wasn't much but on the large rope
platform above the bar I found what I
feel safe to assume this SCP 3087 beasts
home I thought piles of socks some old
looking stuffed animals a little while
in and at least three pictures of sa
p-38s and an a I understand what about a
C p38 87b ah yes well
during all of this from the moment I
ended up there up soon as I emerged I
was terrified I could hear that thing
moving in the dark stoking me
I admit I felt like it was going to kill
me I could see her friends her eyes her
it's close apologies
I was running around screaming I even
fell in the water lost my shoes in the
plastic pond
I tried to find a hole to hide in and I
wouldn't be able to tell you how many
times I filmed the Garonne trying to run
away from sa p-38s and B and yet I don't
think I actually saw it even once how
did you escape from that well I was
cinema corrupt by a say B 30mb it went
like it appeared from the dark but I was
feeling so terrified I just as likely
didn't see approaching she lifted me up
I think she smiled with all those gentle
farmers I was sure she that was going to
eat me when he chose me higher and
opened its mouth instead it wrapped my
socks and pulled them off then started
to chew on them thinking I said thank
you
before toss him into one of the holes I
felt like I was being sucked away there
was darkness pulling an end and next
thing I knew I was back under the bed
with all of you around me I see thank
you really I think we can conclude this
interview here
additional notes after the incident SCP
38 87 a and B were observed talking with
one another as CP 38 87 a relayed as CP
38 87 B's apologies to dr. garden to
date SCP 38 87 B has refused to bring
anyone else into its home ok I think
that about does it for today thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are and I hope you get a good night's
sleep
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Sabha arbiters soul
Darius tan Justin de der Nam and jayvo
Jack Corey Barker
Chloe Harlan and Nathan if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Vulcan thank you
you